this is John Galt speaking
hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with Harman caslo
he's the producer of the Atlas Shrugged
movie project the third and final
installment is coming out September 12th
Harman thanks for talking to us
that's good there they set the stage
what happens for those who are not
absolutely sure the plot of Atlas
Shrugged what's the big finale well well
the book first off the book written more
than fifty years agos 1200 pages split
into three parts and in producing the
movies we decided to follow the
structure of the book so here we are at
part three like parts 1 & 2 made it as a
standalone movie so if you haven't read
the book you'll understand but basically
now we're reaching really the romantic
part of the story where our hero dagny
taggart a very hard-working tenacious
woman who is fighting against the forces
of a brutal over-regulating interfering
government oh yeah yeah we're in DC
right so this is all was easy to say but
she ends up meeting this mysterious
character John Galt and John Galt
you know a talented engineer who worked
for this incredible motor company that
then decided embrace kind of this
Marxist philosophy of paying people not
based on what they produce but based on
need and he was not going to put up with
that and and through the story he starts
recruiting the productive people in
society to leave - in a sense go on
strike yeah and that's the metaphor of
Atlas Shrugged what happens to the world
if the people who really hold it up and
support it disappear exactly and he's
gonna stop in a sense this motor of the
world and so in part three she finally
meets up with the man who has been
systematically taking away from Dagny
the very people she needs to keep her
railroad afloat and and she ends up
going to this incredible place this
atlantis where all these people and this
is of course Galt's Gulch gold sky the
origin of the phrase going Gault
just giving up and moving away and not
putting up with things how how do you
know just can you describe what what
does Galt's Gulch look like well I mean
it's it's a magical place the the the
orange juice is as orange as it could
possibly be there's there's very little
rules or regulations because people
believe in honor and they believe in
free markets they believe in competition
and really it's where they're they're
liberated talk a little bit over the
course of the first two movies 2011 was
the first one how you know how has the
conception of the project changed some
of the reviews have not been kind right
what have you learned along the way yeah
it's a good question so John John a Glee
Laura the the gentleman owns the rights
he you know when we started out it was
how do you adapt faithfully adapt a book
like this there's a many many messages
that I earn Rand is exploring in the
book some about free markets I'm about
relationship some of them are political
in nature and so you know it's trying to
find a cinematic thread right and your
life's edits I mean it's 1,200 pages
it's very general life explicate not
only that but the book has inspired and
influenced so many people and and it's
one of these great pieces of literature
that as you're reading it you begin to
see the movie in your own hat and so you
know one of the things people would
expect to see that movie that they
imagined in their might and so really
what what we've done and try to tell
people is this is more of a celebration
of iron Rand's ideas being able to adapt
this book would require significantly
more time and money than John and I had
to tax it well talk about rands legacy
because this you know she I always think
of her and Jack Kerouac as the two
post-war American writers who still have
a massive influence novelists who have a
massive influence on people they still
Rock people's world what not what is it
about rands
message or method that seems to be you
know I mean it just keeps growing it's
it's you know in a way people like Saul
Bellow you know writers who are
considered much more literary and much
more kind of highbrow don't exert the
same influence over the the day-to-day
culture of someone like ran what what is
her secret well I think that she really
hit a nerve on a lot of people in this
country who believe in a constitutional
republic who sort of embraced perhaps
the libertarian point of view from a
political standpoint who felt like they
needed a voice and she just having come
from Russia and really kind of land in
the land of opportunity and see the
greatness of America to see all the
liberty and freedoms that we had and to
begin to see a government beginning to
take a position that would later on you
know take those freedoms and liberties
away from us and and now here she
written a book wanted to express those
feelings wanted to warn us and so much
of it is happening then I think you know
her legacy is just continues to be
written every day as we see the the
Obama administration in a sense
legislate without going to Congress this
is stuff lifted right out of Atlas
Shrugged what happens when you begin to
let the government get away with things
that are really outside of of what the
founding fathers envisioned you think
you know from from a Hollywood
perspective people always talk about you
know Hollywood is filled with liberals
it's also true that Hollywood is filled
with people who talk about it the
greatness of ein Rand or how I'm Rand
inspired them people like Oliver Stone
Brad Pitt Angelina and Angelina Jolie I
mean across the political spectrum
Hollywood and Iran seem to go together
do you sense there is a thaw in the kind
of political correctness in Hollywood
are people more interested in exploring
libertarian themes or individualist
themes or something different or is it
really as bad as it's always been yeah I
think that well at least what John and I
experienced firsthand was Hollywood
really lacks the courage to take a man
as like iron rants like the one in Atlas
Shrugged and believe that there's
there's an audience for that they're
just there isn't that sort of Kurt so I
think they want to play safe and I think
that they are heavily influenced by
political correctness and there's also
this kind of herd mentality that sort of
collectivist almost mentality that
Hollywood likes to subscribe to this and
a feeling that you know we should be
sacrificing and all these sorts of
concepts that really run well a country
and if you go to all he would get the
sacrifice they make from a seventy
million dollar home isn't too much of a
sovereign's I guess the feeling of guilt
associated that they said do you think
any of that is changing especially as
the kind of studio system seems to break
down or there are alternatives to that
is is production becoming more
decentralized and will that allow more
points of view to be represented yeah I
mean I think that you know Atlas
Shrugged
is actually some people viewed as
science fiction right and looking at for
example Rearden metal is what we now
have is titanium and I think the
Internet is this great technological you
know development that really has knocked
down barriers I think it has Hollywood
very scared you have a lot of players
who now can bring content to anyone on
the planet versus before you you
wouldn't be able to you know reach an
audience unless you were one of these
powerful Studios Atlas Shrugged part
three opens September 12th what's the
best place to get all the information
about the movie is gonna be opening on
September 12th or website Atlas Shrugged
movie.com
just Google Atlas Shrugged we're the
first one under there and and that'll
have a list of all the theaters and I
think people really enjoy seeing not
only the the last part but it will give
them a good sense of the message than in
the real meaning as to why so many
people have been inspired by this great
book alright well we'll leave it there
Harman caslo producer of Atlas Shrugged
the movie it opens the final part of the
Oh G open September 12th thanks Harman
they keen that for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie